Hi I’m Rachel and I am a software engineer
on the Google Accessibility Engineering team.
In this video I want to talk to you about
how you can develop extensions for Chrome
that can be useful for users with disabilities.
For users with disabilities such as blindness,
low vision, deafness, or limited dexterity,
the web can be difficult or even impossible
to navigate. From interfaces that don’t
allow keyboard navigation to text that is
too small to read, users with special needs
can find a lot of obstacles in front of them
and their favorite content. Chrome browser
extensions can help by enabling users to customize
many aspects of the browser and the web.
One extension that I’ve been working on
for a while is called ChromeVis. It’s
an extension that gives you the ability to
magnify any selected text on a webpage.
ChromeVis displays the magnified text inside
of a floating lens, so the original page layout
is preserved.
This extension is intended for users with
low vision, and I have included some key features
that are important to this user group.
First, the extension is completely keyboard
navigable.
You can move the selection around the page
without ever touching the mouse. You can use
keyboard shortcuts to specify whether you
want to move the selection by paragraph, sentence,
word, or even character.
Second, both the lens text color and the lens
background color can be changed.
This is also done through keyboard shortcuts.
This way, you can adjust the lens to achieve
your desired contrast between foreground and
background. And you can save several different
combinations of foreground and background
color.
Finally, we included two layout options for
the lens display.
You can keep the lens anchored at the top
of the window while scrolling the page underneath
it. Or, you can make the lens appear directly
above the selected text, enabling you to see
the magnified text in its original context.
The ChromeVis options page is an important
part of the extension. Here, you can change
the lens colors as well as specify your own
keyboard shortcuts.
This is especially important for users who
might be using screen reading software that
reserves its own keyboard shortcuts, or when
a user is using a web application like GMail
that reserves additional shortcuts.
Any developer can integrate features like
those found in ChromeVis into their extension
because we’re releasing the code as open
source. There are a few features that I think
could be particularly interesting:
To move a selection around a web page automatically,
I relied upon the WebKit selection API. I
call selection.modify whenever I want to move
a selection forward or backward in the page,
and wrapped this call into the functions nextElement
and prevElement.
I also did some additional work to clean up
the selections that selection.modify produces
to ensure logical movement between <div> blocks
and so that blank text nodes or spacer nodes
are not included in a selection.
It was actually a non-trivial problem to determine
the position of selected text, because text
nodes do not have position attributes. I ended
up calculating the position by inserting a
span at the beginning of the selection range,
determining the position of that span, and
then deleting the span.
If you think these functions would be useful,
please feel free to include our selection
JavaScript libraries inside your own extension.
Including keyboard navigation, text size options,
and color options are some simple ways to
make your extensions more accessible to users
and give the browser more flexibility in how
content is displayed. If you want more specific
information on writing accessible extensions,
please see the new Accessibility implementation
guide in the Chrome Extensions Developer’s
Guide at code.google.com/chrome/extensions